what's your thing you did the most in
your life what's the thing you did the
most that you hated I went to school for
[ __ ] yeah forever yes from 6 to 18 I
hated like college is a racket
it is the singular racket college loads
that you can't even declare bankruptcy
to get at us that gives you a piece of
paper that does not map to anything
that's going on in the real world
Zera other than the jobs lawyers doctor
I know the cliche [ __ ] but I'm talking
business and you're not watching this
form or your [ __ ] so business just does
not map is it you're watching this and
you are collecting debt to go to college
to be a business person quit right now
send this email to mom sorry mom Goff
let's start with this I fully fully 100
thousand percent with no hedge do not
believe that you can teach
entrepreneurship right so that's awkward
if there were a defined path to success
especially in any sort of creative
endeavor everyone would just follow that
defined path there is no defined path
and college can be a great way to help
you find one of those paths but it is
certainly not the only way that's
certainly not a guarantee that you'll
find that trajectory there are so many
of you that graduate this month and have
no [ __ ] idea what you want to do and
that's ok most people don't you should
not be stressed about that I'm scared
that you don't realize that you're
entering the greatest five year window
of your life for you to attack the life
that you want to win not because it's
the secret because the world so Zen
because it's [ __ ] hard as [ __ ] out
there you get to live life one time and
this is the time right now to understand
what's actually happening and actually
map your behavior to something that will
impact you for the next 80 years promise
me that you understand that the land
grab of happiness starts right now if
you're lucky enough to be graduating
today but not a [ __ ] idea
what you're going to do with your future
nobody's ever been luckier than you
please recognize